[Musique]
sur sensation
bonjour et bienvenue dans un Europe sur
Radio sensation et sur TV 78 une
émission spéciale enregistrée à Rome une
ville importante pour la construction de
l'Europe avec le 25 mars 1957 il y a 66
ans la signature du traité de Rome
créant la Communauté économique
européenne
voici le sommaire de cette émission 44%
des Italiens ont une image positive de
l'Union européenne mais quand
l'attente-t-il réponse dans un instant
la lutte contre l'immigration
clandestine c'est l'une des priorités du
gouvernement italien nous verrons la
réaction de l'ONG baobab expérience qui
aide les migrants 10 ans de pontificat
pour le pape François a-t-il vraiment
changé l'église qu'a-t-il apporté qu'en
est-il de son état de santé nous
rencontrerons le correspondant du
journal La Croix à Rome en Italie 11,8
millions de personnes parle couramment
le français l'Institut français centre
Saint-Louis de Rome assure la promotion
de la francophonie et de la culture
française vous verrez
en Europe
[Musique]
44% des Italiens ont une image positive
de l'Union européenne contre 36% des
Français qu'est-ce que les Italiens
attendent de l'Europe avec l'extrême
droite au pouvoir les relations entre
l'Union européenne et l'Italie
risque-t-elle de se dégrader j'ai
rendez-vous avec le professeur Raphaël
et Torino coordinateur du Centre Europe
Direct de l'université romatrie
zone Europe
l'Italie a été l'un des 6 pays
fondateurs de l'Union européenne c'est
même ici à Rome qui a été signé les deux
traités que l'on considère aujourd'hui
comme les traités fondateurs de l'Union
européenne un homme politique italien
incarnait fortement cette idée
européenne c'est alcider des gasperies
oui bien sûr si des esclaves pays
étaient en politicien italien il était
un président très célèbre de la
démocratie chrétienne qui a été premier
ministre et chef provisoire de détails
italiens pendant les périodes entre la
fin de la deuxième guerre mondiale et
les débuts de la démocratie républicaine
italienne il y a considéré un de peur
fonda des l'Union européenne mais il a
aussi eu des Italiens pas moi
d'important comme altirospinali qui a
été aussi les critères et les penseurs
des du manifestent des vento tenais en
on dit que les pères fondament de
l'Union européenne on a été assis des
dégâts Spinelli donc nous sommes bien
contents d'être été entre les pays
fondateurs
du Parlement européen alors si on
regarde c'est 20 dernières années
l'Europe a traversé de nombreuses
épreuves introduction de l'euro crise
économique en 2008 la crise migratoire
en 2015 la pandémie puis l'Italie a été
en première ligne de ses nombreux défis
au niveau qu'on a tous connu au niveau
européen est-ce que tout cela on a un
peu le sentiment en Italie que ça a fait
naître un peu de déception sur le projet
européen est-ce que c'est ce que vous
pensez aussi ah j'y pense qui est
surtout après la pandémie de covid du
covid les Italiens ont gagné encore un
peu plus de fiducies dans l'Union
européenne parce qu'on a vu nous sommes
les pays qui est plus bénéfices du
européen des next generations you et
donc les Italiens ont vu que l'Europe
peut être pragmatiquement
en aide pour l'Italie donc si c'était
vrai que il y a 10 ans 15 ans la
philosophie des Italiens a été un peu
baissé mais maintenant nous sommes je
pense que les Italiens ont beaucoup de
philosophie dans l'Union européenne en
quoi justement l'Union européenne est
important pour l'Italie alors
aujourd'hui je pense que d'un point de
vue général une pince est importante
parce que c'est un modèle on peut dire
que en Europe dans l'Europe dans
l'Europe nous pouvons mieux manifester
notre idée notre valeur plus importante
c'est aussi important parce que c'est
vrai que l'Union européenne à travers
l'Union européenne l'Italie reçoit
beaucoup d'aide économiques et
financières on a vu tout à l'heure vous
avez dit que les Italiens ont encore foi
en l'Union européenne pourtant ils ont
élu Giorgia Meloni comme première
ministre elle n'est pas forcément au
départ en tout cas pour son neurophilie
envers l'Union européenne est-ce que les
Italiens sont eurosceptiques finalement
cette élection ne veut rien dire j'ai
pas ce qui est l'élection du George
Meloni a été un passage important dans
notre histoire parce que c'était a été
la première ministre femme des de
l'Italie a été la première ministre qui
vient un peu de la droite italienne
parce que suivre que George Amélie c'est
vraiment bien conduite
immédiatement car elle a eu
ses rapporté avec les autres chefs
politiques de l'Europe et on peut dire
que la position italienne avec George
Emiliani c'est pas très différent de la
position qui ne nous avons eu avec Mario
Draghi alors sur la guerre en Ukraine
justement l'Italie c'est aligné avec
l'Union européenne elle soutient Kiev
très fortement pourtant Sylvie
oberlusconi qui fait partie de
l'alliance de la coalition avec Georgia
Meloni était un est un grand ami de
Vladimir Poutine est-ce que on en parle
un petit peu en Italie de tout ça on
parle beaucoup des chats parce que
l'alliance qui soutient George jamilon
il s'était formé par Georgio Milone ici
vieux belluconi et
Sabine et en effet on voit qui dans
cette alliance il y a un peu de
compodies en français
bouleversement sur ce point parce que si
connaissais plus proche à une position
je ne veux pas dire proche celui de ma
plus proche à la paix à à tout prix à
tout prix George mélodie c'est plus
rigide sur ça déjà mélodie il veut
soutenir l'Ukraine il vous soutenir les
forces de l'Union européenne et donc il
y a un peu décontracte dans l'alliance
mais qui pour le moment il semble qu'il
peut le gérer alors pour les Italiens il
y a un sujet qui est très important
c'est la question migratoire qu'est-ce
qu'ils attendent de l'Union européenne
euh ça c'est vrai et en effet ça la
question que elle est la plus importante
pour l'Italie pour les Italiens parce
que notre possession géographique fait
de l'Italie en point d'arrivée j'ai
entendu
avec l'Espagne oui mais maintenant
j’étais en train de lire un rapport dans
les premiers 4 mois de l'année nous
avons reçu plus de 20000 personnes Malta
a reçu une personne
l'Espagne a eu pendant deux trois mille
et donc nous sommes la porte d'entrée de
l'Europe et maintenant nous avons les
mêmes numéros qui nous avons dans les
premiers 4 mois à quatre mois de la
crise migratoire de 2015 donc ça c'est
un problème sérieux c'est un problème
qu'il faut manager parce que maintenant
la route principale c'est de la dès la
Tunisie à l'Italie est-ce qu'il y a
d'autres sujets aussi qui intéressent
fortement les Italiens on pense à la
santé aussi
qui a été durement frappé pendant la
pandémie un peu oui bien sûr la question
migratoire mais c'est aussi la question
de l'énergie nous ayons un peu avec des
craintes
les fées qui ne trouvent pas une
position unique comment européenne parce
que nous voyons que la France prend sa
position la Germanie l'Allemagne prend
sa position et l'Espagne sa position et
nous pensons qu'il nous doit nous devons
vraiment aller à Monsieur commune de
l'énergie pour contraster efficacement
ce qui se passe pour autant avec la
Russie maintenant mais peut-être avec un
autre pays dans la dans le futur nous
voyons qu'il faut être plus européen
encore une fois gratuit
[Musique]
la chanteuse
la lutte contre l'immigration
clandestine est l'une des priorités de
la première ministre italienne Giorgia
Meloni un nouveau décret a d'ailleurs
été pris récemment pour durcir les
peines contre les passeurs mais
certaines ONG qui viennent en aide aux
migrants craignent aussi d'être accusés
de complicité rencontre avec Andrea
Costa président et fondateur de baobab
expérience
zone Europe
avec la Grèce et l'Espagne l'Italie est
l'une des portes d'entrée en Europe en
termes d'immigration en 2022 72000
clandestins sont arrivés dans le pays en
2016 au moment de la crise migratoire
qu'a connu l'Europe vous avez décidé
Andréa Costa de créer cette association
baobab expérience pourquoi est-ce que
vous avez créé au Bob l’expérience
déjà c'est important de dire que nous
nous lançons en 2015-2016 parce qu'il y
a un grand nombre de débarquements
de migrants qui ont débarqué en Italie
ne veulent pas s'arrêter en Italie
ils ne veulent pas rester en Italie ce
n'est pas leur destination finale mais
ils veulent se diriger vers d'autres
pays européens dans la France
l'Allemagne l'Angleterre les Pays-Bas et
la Belgique
et à cette époque et encore aujourd'hui
le migrant qui est donc en mouvement le
migrant transit n'était pas prise en
considération par les autorités par les
institutions
dans la société civile un mouvement de
citoyen de citoyenne qui aident les
migrants dans leur passage en Italie de
leur débarquement en Sicile sur les
côtes sud à Lampedusa jusqu'à leur
arrivée vers les frontières nord à
Vintimille et Suze qui sont les
frontières avec la France les villes de
Menton et de Montgenèvre et aussi avec
la Suisse à brenero pour aller en
Autriche et en Allemagne
et pourquoi avoir nommé cette
association baobab experience comment
est-ce que vous avez eu l'idée de ce nom
quoi ce nom mais père que baobabina
ce nom parce que le baobab en Afrique
c'est l'arbre de la vie c'est un arbre
avec
très grand tronc qui protège le voyageur
il protège le voyageur s'il pleut
fortement il le protège de l'eau s'il y
a beaucoup de soleil il crée une grande
ombre qui le protège du soleil et
surtout parce qu'en 2015 quand d'un coup
il y a eu des centaines de migrants dans
nos rues nous nous occupions d'un vieux
centre d'accueil qui s'appelait baobab
et donc à partir de là nous avons décidé
de garder ce nom et d'appeler
l'association baobab expérience
vous vous aidez donc les migrants qui
arrivent sur Rome comment est-ce que
vous faites pour les aider vous les
accueillez mais pas seulement vous
proposez aussi d'autres d'autres types
d'aide si méliami
le baobab au-delà de s'occuper des
migrants qui sont en transit qui sont en
mouvement c'est aussi occupé de ces
migrants qui demandent l'asile en Italie
et qui s'arrête à
au début il s'agissait de leur donner de
la nourriture de leur donner découvertes
de leur donner des matelas des sacs de
couchage et des vêtements
et puis nous nous sommes rendus compte
que ce n'est pas seulement de ça ont
besoin des migrants en effet ils ont
besoin d'abord au minimum d'informations
d'informations sur comment obtenir des
papiers d'une aide dans la recherche
d'un travail dans la recherche d'un
logement d'une aide sanitaire
je rappelle que celui qui vient de Libye
a passé des mots difficiles dans les
camps en Libye lors de la traversée en
mer et donc nous avons commencé à
développer nos activités sur d'autres
aspects également de l'aide aux migrants
ces dernières années le discours anti
immigration l'a emporté en
vous défendez vous une autre vision des
flux migratoires comment est-ce que vous
voyez les choses si non il y a
solotamine tu as bien mon avis
absolument nous avons une vision
différente de celle de tous les
gouvernements de ces dernières années
sur
l'immigrations
le concept d'invasion surtout parce
qu'une bonne partie des migrants la
politique et la presse sont sont
maintenant rendus compte ne s'arrête pas
en Italie donc s'il y a invasions c'est
plutôt en France en Allemagne en Espagne
dans les autres pays
mais ce n'est pas en Italie qu'il y a
une invasion c'est un pays qui est en
train de s'appauvrir en termes de
population notre pays perd 250
000 habitants chaque année mais nous
nous contestons ce qui a été la
narration sur l'immigration comme elle a
été racontée c'est-à-dire qu'elle a été
vu comme un danger comme une atteinte à
notre sécurité nous nous croyons que
c'est vrai que la sécurité est un enjeu
quand on parle d'immigration mais il
s'agit de la sécurité des hommes des
femmes et des enfants qui sont obligés
d'abandonner leur propre pays aisés et
culpabiliser une personne seulement
parce qu'elle migre n'est pas juste de
notre avis migrer n'est pas une
infraction et surtout les migrants ne
sont pas un danger ils sont plutôt
eux-mêmes en danger
selon vous l'immigration ne cause pas de
problème que ce soit en termes
d'intégration de sécurité
sous l'intégration
je crois qu'il peut y avoir des
problèmes si on investit pas sur
l'intégration si on investit pas sur
l'accueil
nous disons toujours qu'investir sur
l'accueil plutôt que sur la construction
de murs
un investissement sur la sécurité de
tous surtout celle des migrants mais
aussi de toute la communauté
en ce qui concerne la sécurité il n'y a
aucune donnée qui dit que les migrants
augmentent la criminalité
nous sommes en train de parler de
l'Italie le pays de la mafia de la
Camorra des attentats c'est un pays qui
par rapport à il y a 20 30 ans même 10
ans et plus sûr et pourtant la politique
pour des motifs électoraux et c'est
d'appuyer sur le bouton de la peur et de
la sécurité
mais ce sont des données qui ne
correspondent pas à la réalité
non correspondante la première ministre
Giorgia Meloni a annoncé récemment un
décret visant à alourdir les peines les
sanctions envers les passeurs est-ce que
vous pensez vous aussi qui qu'il failli
lutter contre le système de passeur
moi je crois que les personnes comme
nous
qui accueille bénévolement
ce sont des personnes qui sont les
ennemis numéro 1 des trafiquants ah mais
c'est une blague il me semble que
derrière ces slogans du gouvernement de
Georgia Meloni se cache en fait une
politique qui aide les vrais trafiquants
moi je pense à l'argent donné par
l'Europe et surtout par l'Italie aux
soi-disant garde-côte libyens au groupe
armés que se divise la Libye au
dictateur comme
erdo a un en Turquie qui encaisse
beaucoup d'argent de l'Europe et de
l'Italie pour contenir les migrants mais
qui ouvre le robinet quand il le
souhaite pour gérer leurs flux ils les
utilisaient comme un moyen d'avoir plus
d'argent
nous avons assisté en Italie mais aussi
en France je pense à notre ami et Cédric
Herrou à la criminalisation de la
solidarité
qui commet on a essayé de faire passer
des gens comme nous qui agissent
solidairement vers les migrants comment
réaliser des trafiquants si nous
trafiquons nous trafiquons en humanité
aucun de nous est un trafiquant aucun de
nous est un passeur nous revendiquons la
liberté de mouvement de toutes et de
tous et avec Céline directrices nous
effectuons notre travail
que vous êtes le fondateur de baobab
expérience
[Musique]
au cœur de Rome le Vatican le plus petit
État du monde est dirigé depuis le 13
mars 2013 par le pape François retour
sur les 10 premières années de son
pontificat avec Lou Bémont de ces
Neville correspondant du journal La
Croix à Rome
il y a 10 ans les cardinaux de l'Église
catholique réunit en conclave ont choisi
le cardinal de Buenos Aires Georges et
Mario bergolio pour devenir le 266ème
pape de l'Église catholique c'était le
premier pape non européen c'était aussi
le premier pape jésuite en quelques mots
c'était le pape de la nouveauté c'est
pas François oui ça a été le pape de la
nouveauté d'abord parce que comme vous
l'avez dit c'est un pape qui vient de
loin qui vient d'Argentine donc de
l'autre bout du monde même
géographiquement symboliquement
culturellement et puis c'est un pape qui
a beaucoup joué sur les symboles la
rupture qui joue encore aujourd'hui sur
sur les symboles et la rupture et donc
voilà c'est c'est un pape qui vient de
loin
euh à la fois pour la culture de
l'Église catholique qui est très
occidentale et qui est assez
européenocentré occidentale au centre et
en même temps d'un point de vue
géographique c'est-à-dire c'est un pape
qui a la connaissance d'autres cultures
d'autres continents et notamment
d'autres manières de penser l'Église
catholique dans le grand sud de la
moitié sud de du monde alors 10 ans
c'est aussi l'occasion de faire le bilan
justement de son pontificat un premier
bilan il a été mandaté au départ pour
réformer la curie par les cardinaux
lutter contre le cléricalisme la place
des femmes dans l'église aussi lutter
contre les abus sexuels assainir aussi
les finances du Vatican qui était il y a
10 ans en déficit ainsi il a réussi à
réformer l'Église de Pape François
alors il y a pas vraiment de réponse oui
ou non à cette question il a impulsé un
certain nombre de réformes dans l'Église
catholique c'est sûr que la réforme
c'est l'un des marqueurs de ce
pontificat de ces 10 premières années si
on peut dire il y en aura pas 10 autres
mais en tout cas de ces dix années c'est
vraiment un marqueur réforme à
l'intérieur de la machine à l'intérieur
de la curie ou effectivement voilà ça
correspondait à une demande qui avait
été faite par les cardinaux en 2013 mais
aussi réformes à l'extérieur de l'église
de l'esprit de l'église de la manière de
prendre ses décisions d'écouter les
fidèles voilà et aussi réforme vis-à-vis
de deux grandes questions ici très
importantes à Rome les finances et les
abus sexuels la pédocriminalité donc
voilà effectivement un pape de réforme
mais vous savez la réforme dans l'Église
catholique c'est pas un truc qui se
décide en cinq ans en 10 ans on est
plutôt sur des horizons de 50 ans sur
les processus long donc voilà il lance
des choses et après on sera en réalité
dans un peu plus que que 10 ans si si
les réformes ont fonctionné et si elle
continue à être bien présente engagé
aussi sur les questions
environnementales et écologiques
l'Église catholique a été une
institution pionnière en la matière de
sur la lutte contre l'environnement je
pense pas qu'elle a été premier je pense
pas qu'elle a été pionnière parce que
voilà il y a d'autres institutions
internationales je pense à l'ONU je
pense enfin voilà quoi qui ont joué ces
rôles là et puis aussi d'un certain
nombre de gouvernements dans les pays du
Sud notamment de pays d'études mais ce
qui est sûr c'est que depuis 10 ans et
avec l'avènement de ce pape et avec le
l'insistance de ce pape il y a une
insistance particulière sur l'écologie
parce que le pape François a fait
rentrer l'écologie dans le cœur de la
pensée et des préoccupations catholiques
avant l'écologie voilà le la nécessité
de prendre soin de l'environnement de la
maison commune voilà de la création
c'était quelque chose d'un peu
périphérique là c'est devenu quelque
chose de central d'ailleurs il l'a mis
au centre d'une encyclique qui a été
publiée en 2015 une grande encyclique
verte et sociale et donc effectivement
c'est celui qui a fait rentrer en les
préoccupations écologiques au cœur de
l'Église catholique et au cœur de ce
qu'on appelle le magistère c'est-à-dire
voilà le l'endroit où est pensé la
doctrine de l'Église catholique
un pape qui dialogue aussi en disant il
a rencontré plusieurs autres
représentants religieux notamment avec
les orthodoxes et les musulmans quelle
relation a-t-il avec les autres
religions
c'est un pape qui depuis le début de son
pontificat veut bâtir des ponts vous
savez il dit souvent pontifax donc c'est
le pontife en latin c'est celui qui
bâtit des ponts et il emploie souvent
cette expression effectivement notamment
avec le monde musulman voilà c'est
quelqu'un qui a voulu
jeter des ponts entamer des dialogues
aussi bien avec les sunnites et le grand
imam d'alaza que les chiites en Irak
notamment avec
l'ayatollah Ali alcistani lorsqu'il a
été en Irak pour ce voyage historique en
2021 et puis effectivement avec les
orthodoxes notamment avec le Patriarche
de Moscou qui rile vous savez que ça a
été la première rencontre depuis la
grande rupture entre Lorient et
l'Occident dans l'Église catholique
entre Rome et et l'orthodoxie et donc